en este vídeo que va a hacer muchos
ejercicios de los que aparecen en las
pruebas estandarizadas y que nos
ayudarán en nuestro módulo de
divisibilidad por ejemplo aquí tenemos
este que dice todos los números
divisibles entre 12 y 20 también son
divisibles entre en este problema lo que
tengo que observar es que cualquier
número que sea divisible entre 12 y 20
tendrá que ser divisible entre los
factores primos de 12 y 20 a ver veamos
por ejemplo el 12 es está aquí quiénes
son sus factores primos bueno pues 12 es
2 por 6 y 6 quién es pues dos por tres
así que el 12 sus factores primos factor
izando en primos es 2 por dos por tres
así que todo número que sea divisible
entre 12 tendrá que ser divisible por
dos veces dos y un tres por dos por dos
por tres
ahora vamos con el 20 cuál es su
factorización de 20 entonces 20
2 por 10
y 10 es 2 por 5
así que todos los números que sean
divisibles entre 20 tendrán que ser
divisibles entre 2 por 2 por 5 y
entonces todos los números que sean
divisibles entre 12 y 20 tendrán que ser
divisibles por todos sus factores primos
o sea aquí tenemos el 2 el 2 y el 3 del
12 estos son los que están aquí y en el
20 tenemos dos veces 2 es lo que tenemos
aquí bueno el 13 del 12 dice faltaría
agregar el 5 así que todos los números
divisibles entre 12 y 20 tendrán que ser
divisible entre todos estos factores
primos y de hecho este número que está
aquí que es 60 es el mínimo común
múltiplo de 12 y 20 o sea que todos los
números divisibles entre 12 y 20 pues
tendrán que ser divisibles entre este
número que está aquí
y de hecho este como dijimos es el
mínimo común múltiplo puede haber otros
números más grandes por ejemplo el
factor le vamos a llamar a b c o sea son
números que multiplican a este que tengo
acá pero como no sabemos exactamente
cuáles son los valores de abc en fin 90
no vamos a atender estos números mayores
porque no podemos saber exactamente de
ellos entonces estos los vamos a indicar
así con una interrogación
pero en fin esto ahora nada más por
mencionarlo entonces veamos ahora casos
específicos de números que sí sabemos
que son divisibles entre este número que
está aquí por ejemplo si yo tengo el 2
el 2 definitivamente es divisible entre
esto que está aquí porque aquí aparece
el 2 ahora veamos el 2 x 2
2 por 2 pues también bueno que de hechos
4 pues también es divisible entre este
número que está aquí es decir todas las
combinaciones de números que yo haga con
estos factores primos serán números
divisibles entre este número que tengo
aquí por ejemplo también puedo agarrar
el 2 por 3 es el 6 y aquí aparece el 2 y
el 3 y también por ejemplo podría
agarrar el 3 por 5 porque aquí parece
mentes y el 5 y regresando a nuestro
problema pues este es un ejercicio de
opción múltiple y entonces me preguntan
a ver me preguntan
por si estos números son divisibles
entre 12 y 20 y la lista incluye al 7
incluye al 9 tenemos al 12 y tenemos al
8 entonces veamos cada uno de ellos
entonces empezamos por el 7 el 7 resulta
que es un número primo y entonces pues
ninguno de estos factores son factores
del 7 entonces el 7 no funciona el 9 es
3 por 3
entonces yo tendría que tener en estos
factores que están aquí dos veces 3 2 3
pero no no lo tengo entonces el 9
tampoco funciona el 12 4 resulta que 12
es 2 por dos por tres como ya lo
platicábamos
y entonces el 12 definitivamente si
funciona y el 88 es dos por dos por dos
o sea tres veces el dos pero aquí yo
nada más tengo dos veces dos entonces el
8 no funciona pues muy bien vayamos a
otro
vamos a mover esto que está aquí y
hagamos otro ejercicio bien en el
siguiente problema que vamos a hacer
este a ver vamos a pensar en algo
similar y con unos números interesantes
por ejemplo
este problema ahora va a decir algo así
como en todos los números todos los
menos
y visibles
entre 9
y también
son divisibles
/
y entonces ok todos los números que sean
divisibles entre 9 y 24 tendrán que ser
visibles entre los factores primos de 9
y 24 veamos los factores primos de estos
números entonces empecemos con el 9
quién es el 9 quiénes son sus factores
primos entonces 9 estrés
esto quiere decir que todos los números
que sean divisibles entre 9 tienen que
ser visibles entre 3 por 3 muy bien
vamos con el 24 el 24 es dos veces 12
2 y es dos veces 6
y seis es dos veces tres y ya terminamos
eso quiere decir que los factores primos
de 24 es dos por dos por dos por tres y
todos los números que sean divisibles
entre 24 tendrán que ser divisibles
entre estos factores primos entonces
vamos a ponerlos junto a los que aquí
tenemos entonces tenemos tres veces dos
dos por dos por dos
y el 3 aquí ya lo tenemos entonces este
número que está aquí que de hecho 72 es
el número que está hecho con todos los
factores primos de 9 y 24 lo que es lo
mismo los números que sean divisibles
entre 9 y 24 tendrán que ser divisibles
entre todos estos factores primos y
continuamos con nuestro ejercicio
entonces en nuestro ejercicio nos van a
preguntar cómo es de opción múltiple y
nos van a preguntar acerca de los
siguientes números o sea nos van a
preguntar por el 16
nos van a preguntar por el 27 queremos
también saber por el 5 y el 11
el 9 muy bien entonces veamos cada uno
de ellos quienes 16 16 es 2
por 2 por 2 por 2 o sea 2 a la cuarta
potencia yo tendría que encontrar de
este lado 4 veces el 2 pero eso no es
cierto nada más 6 3
entonces el 16 no es un número divisible
entre 9 y 24
vámonos con el 27 quienes 27 pues es 3
por 3 por 3 y entonces yo tendría que
encontrar 3 veces 3 en este número que
está de este lado pero nada más está 2
veces entonces el 27 tampoco funciona el
5 el 5 resulta que es un número primo
entonces aquí tendría que aparecer el 5
como no hay 5 el 5 no funciona el 11 es
el mismo caso es otro número primo y
aquí no hay 11 tampoco funciona
el 9 a pues el 9 es 3 x 3
y aquí por supuesto que ahí tenemos tres
por tres pero claro
chispas creo que escogí males de este
candidato porque obviamente está entre
la pregunta así que bueno este no tenía
mucho chiste pero pero bueno el 9 si
funciona y lo mismo pasaría con
cualquier combinación de los factores
primos que se encuentran en este en este
número por ejemplo qué pasa con el 8
bueno pues el 8 es 2 por 2 por 2 3 veces
el 2 lo cual sí aparece muy bien lo
mismo ocurriría con el 4 que es 2 por 2
2 veces 2 pues también va alguien que
está muy bien y lo mismo ocurriría con
el 6 porque tenemos el 2 y el 3 y lo
mismo ocurriría con el 18 porque tenemos
dos por tres por tres en fin espero
haberte confundido y nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo